ja man dinge
das sieht ja aus wie eine wurst rechts
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich jedes gut mir geht es soweit
ganz gut ich bin hier mal wieder in
meinem neuen büro ja es ist es heißt
hier das problem ist noch nicht wir
haben ja draußen bisher alle 33 grad
zumindest ihr 34 grad sogar und hier ist
die rolle der defekt die geht irgendwie
nicht runter das heißt das fenster ist
biene heizung also ist so heiß weil halt
die ganze zeit die sonne drauf knallt
naja deswegen habe ich auch für diese
super entspannte hemd an
habt ihr mich schon mal in seinem hemd
gesehen ich glaube nicht oder wir machen
heute mal wieder etwas anderes als das
was ihr sonst von mir gewohnt seid also
ich wollte das eigentlich schon vor zwei
drei jahren mal machen als ich damals
immer diese videos gemacht habt halt
auch weil es gibt ja offensichtlich
andauernd so irgendwelche fei produkte
oder irgendwelche extrem lustigen
anzeigen die dort geschaltet werden
wurde und ihr dann denkst alter bergauf
reist deswegen so oder wer kauft so was
überhaupt oder wo leute dann irgendwas
bestellen und dann irgendwas komplett
anderes bekommen ja damals gab es ja
noch nicht so viel konnte dass du das
hat sich jetzt geändert und ich würde
sagen wir schauen sie uns an es wird
wirklich lustig und viel spaß aber den
kanal und die leute fangen wir mal ganz
lässig an
das ist so das ist so also ich kann
nicht so nachvollziehen ich kann mir
auch sehr gut vorstellen ist das von
vicious kann man jetzt hier natürlich
nicht ganz genau sehen aber wir haben in
der tasse da sollte eigentlich fakt
draufstehen und dieser henkel sollte als
agieren und dann hat der produzent davon
deshalb falsch und drauf geklebt und das
ist halt auch so eine massenproduktion
abfällt gar nicht aufpasst schon ab nach
deutschland und los
das ist es ist ja schon echt dumm mein
gott das ist auch
das problem ist immer wenn man etwas
bestellt ich hatte das schon so oft ich
habe china schreibt bestellt eben mir
diese lampe zum beispiel auch ja diese
auf dem foto so riesig aus und in echt
ist es dann meistens viel kleiner und
hier steht darunter
der boss von dem hat 50 neue stühle
gestellt und das sind halt alles so mini
dinger open 9 11 also hier haben wir
egal ob es jetzt wissen wo war es gibt
ja so viele seiten und auf jeder seite
gibt es extrem viele von so kleidern
oder christian kleid oder oder sonne
bluse die ich weiß gar nicht wie man es
auf jeden fall sehen ja die werbefotos
kennt man ja eigentlich da sind dann
einmal so richtig schöne frauen trauern
und das kleid findet so perfekt am
körper das macht so richtige kurven hier
jetzt nicht ganz so aber es sieht schon
weiß aus links und was dort angekommen
ist ist hier rechts und da denkst du dir
wirklich so also das ist extrem so habe
ich das jetzt noch nie erlebt aber ich
weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
das hat ja gar keine ähnlichkeit die
arme nachher war bestimmt günstig hier
haben wir das nächste beispiel für
größenunterschiede das foto ist ein
einfach so ein riesiger du denkst dir
etwas so großes stofftier nur 15 euro
und dann kommt so ein kleiner verkappter
husky hund oder was das sein soll an das
ist ja echt immer verrückter es gibt
oftmals angebote da kann man da kann man
dann
[Musik]
da kann man irgendwie so sein eigenes
design drauf custom ihren oder wie man
es nennen und er wollte halt ein foto
drauf haben vielleicht vielleicht
konntest du nur im text drauf schreiben
und hat dann halt diese beiden links
dahin geschickt wo dann halt sich ein
foto hinterher verbirgt sozusagen und
der hersteller hat einfach die links
drauf gedrückt läuft nächstes beispiel
ja alter das hat auch also wir haben
hier wieder so ein sehr hübsches kleid
wie sonst an märchenkleid und das war's
dann angekommen ist hat er überhaupt
keine ähnlichkeit damit ist sie sehr
grausam aus ich habe auch schon mal ein
pool bei uns bestellt der war dann in
echt deutlich kleiner als ich eigentlich
dachte aber dass hier treibt sie auf die
spitze das ist ja der der pool oder was
auch immer das sein soll ist so groß wie
ein schuh da kannst du deinen schülerin
waschen aber da kann es ja nicht drin
baden
es wird wirklich dass das überhaupt
erlaubt ist
das ist ja das noch einfach nur
verarsche auch ich mein ich muss
wirklich sagen ich hatte ich habe
bestimmt schon ohne scheiß ich habe
bestimmt schon 500 produkte oder amerika
sagen wir über 500 produkte habe ich das
schon bestellt und ich hatte nur ganz
ganz wenige wo ich so dachte alter das
ist ja gar nicht das was auf dem foto da
angezeigt wurde aber das hier stellt
euch mal vor ich habe also ich hab noch
nie ein teppich gekauft aber dieser
partie der teppich hier sieht ja
wirklich schön aus also ich würde ihn
zwar nicht in lila bestellen aber dann
dann kommt einfach dass da an so hat
zwar auch nur zwei euro gekostet aber
trotzdem
mir tut das immer so weh so etwas zu
sehen das ist das nächste beispiel wir
haben wir so eine sehr schöne kugel
wieso fast wie so eine vase a kugl wo
sich so eine stadt drin spiegelt und
dann ist einfach das angekommen
also ich weiss nicht wieder die
rechtslage ist aber an sich wenn du halt
nun wurde es jetzt in diesem fall hier
von dem verkäufer weil da kann sich auch
jeder verkaufen bayerisch voll verarscht
aber für fünf euro würde ich mir
wahrscheinlich auch nicht die mühe
machen das dann irgendwie anzuzeigen
oder so dass wir sind ja aus wie eine
wurst rechts das sieht ja aus wie song
my cars minimieren karnevalskostüm ich
gehe als wurst und links zu dieser
mantel wir schön männlich auf herren
style angelehnt natürlich dann auch die
passende krawatte dazu das sieht ja
wirklich schick aus da werden ja dann
auch einfach für diese produktfotos ganz
andere produkte verwendet die eine viel
bessere qualität haben als die sachen
die du dann halt bekommen nun irgendwie
trotzdem die menschen hier muss ich
jetzt wirklich sagen
also ich weiß gar nicht ob man das jetzt
unbedingt als fehler bezeichnen muss das
steht ihr schon sehr gut hier was sie
bekommen hat also das produkt und
natürlich sieht das hier nochmal
hochwertiger und besser aus anderen
sieht schon nicht schlecht aus wobei
wenn sie damit an karneval geht muss er
sich wahrscheinlich tausende anderen hey
ich würde ich so gern auf essen also das
finde ich eigentlich ganz neues online
alte wasd tasten
stellt euch mal vor wie planlos egal in
welcher stadt du bist jede stadt hat ja
diese eigenen merge artikel und so und
es laufen ja durch viele städte auch
diese ganzen verkäufer die dann diese
ganze gefälschte ware dabei haben
möchten du kaufen und original hohen der
prozent und anscheinend hat die ebenso
ein hersteller dafür so wenig
allgemeinbildung dass er das
das macht mich wirklich fertig hier
heute das ist wirklich das jetzt das
verrückteste das trifft ja gar nicht
rechts das sieht wirklich aus rheine
spider man auch ruhiggestellt und links
das sieht aus keine ahnung was das sein
soll auf jeden fall lägen hier zwischen
welten ein alter ja man das also ich
kann davon ein lied singen
ihr könnt euch das wirklich nicht
vorstellen das ist jetzt das letzte foto
heute aber ich habe auf wunsch auch
schon eine menge schuhe bestellt gucci
fakes valencia und keine ahnung was dann
auch alles live und wenn man immer in
deutschland in irgendeinem
schuhgeschäften schuh kauft man kann
sich das nicht vorstellen wie komisch
sich diese schuhe anfühlen und ich kann
es absolut glauben dass die sohle bei
manchen ziemlich leicht wegbricht weil
die die qualität ist grausam die
qualität also es liegt auch irgendwo
nahe ich meine wenn so ein exemplar nur
20 euro kostet aber das hat mich oftmals
schon sehr schockiert leute ich würde
sagen das reicht erstmal es hat mich auf
jeden fall gut zum lachen gebracht ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr sagt man auf
jeden fall noch ein paar dazu lassen
doch nach oben da abonniert sehr gerne
den kanal und wir sehen uns dann ich
hoffe in zukunft auch wieder öfter hier
wieder bin auf jeden fall gerade noch
ein bisschen im umzug schon so was alles
und das wird aber bald und dann habe ich
auch wieder genug zeit haut rein
[Musik]